Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and today
I'm revealing 36 devilish details you missed
in Lucifer Season 5
from crazy easter eggs to hilarious meta references
and and ingenious production design.
Spoiler altert, it is gonna be epic.
The third episode of Season 5 is perhaps one
of the funniest in the series so far as Lucifer
and Chloe investigate a murder on the set
of ¡Diablo!,
a network TV procedural show that's an hilariously
OTT version of Lucifer.
Some of the jokes are more obvious riffs on
the characters we know and love
"Like I keep telling you, Detective Doofus..."
a reference to Lucifer's "Detective Douche"
nickname for Dan.
But others are a bit more subtle, such as
the show's billboard with Diablo's name in
neon lights, just like the original Season
1 Lucifer poster.
And then there's Diablo's version of Lucifer's
mojo power:
"You want to find the killer, figure out their
yearning."
Right.
Isn't there a better word for that?"
Although Luci evidently doesn't like the word
"yearn", he did actually say it himself in
Season 1 when he used his mojo against a corrupt
LAPD detective.
"What do you yearn for in that...
rotten soul of yours?"
When Ella finds the murder weapon that killed
Diablo, she calls it "the only blade that
can kill the Devil".
This is actually a sneaky reference to Azrael's
Blade which featured heavily in the Season
2 episode "Trip To Stabby Town" where it got
close to killing Lucifer when Dan wielded
it in anger against him.
In episode 2, Chloe can see Michael isn't
really acting like Lucifer normally would,
and she tries to get him to do something typically
inappropriate by giving him Dan's dessert
to eat.
"Is that my pudding?
Yes, here you go Daniel.
OK.
What's your game?
Did you spit in it?
He spit in it."
The issue of Lucifer pinching his pudding
has been a recurring joke throughout the series
ever since Luci stole it in Season 2.
"I know you ate my pudding!"
And another time, Dan even discovered that
Luci's mum, Charlotte, was also stealing his
pudding.
In fact, there was a whole episode in Season
3 devoted to a crime that occurred at the
dessert factory:
"Pudding Plus is my favorite, okay?
Twice as much protein as all the other brands."
But poor Dan, never really gets a break, because
when the real Lucifer returns from Hell in
Season 5, he starts using Dan's mug for his
whiskey drinking at the police precinct.
The noir episode is a lot of fun with loads
of easter eggs and references hidden in the
background.
When Lucifer and P.I. Jack Monroe go to visit
Willy the Sausage Prince, they find him getting
his portrait painted while ridiculously dressed
as a knight.
And if you take a closer look on the walls,
there are lots more portraits of Willy,
who clearly sees and models himself after
old European royalty because there's a portrait
of him in the exact same style as a famous
painting of England's King Henry VIII,
and there's another portrait of him that looks
very much like the style of this painting
of the French King Francis I.
Then there's the nightclub where Lily Rose,
aka Lilith, sings which is appropriately named
the "Garden Club"
because Lilith originally lived with Adam
in the Garden of Eden and kept a piece of
the garden in her ring.
And her flowery name in the show, Lily Rose,
is another nice nod to her Garden of Eden
origins.
Inside the club behind the bar is Al Capone's
machine gun with a plaque that reads: "Thanks
For Listening".
Of course, customers sometimes pour their
problems out to bartenders who have a reputation
as sympathetic listeners,
so it's no coincidence that Linda, who's a
therapist in the modern-day world of Lucifer,
turns out to be the bartender at the club
Al Capone frequented.
But there's an extra layer to this reference
because the noir episode is set in 1946,
which is the same year that the real-life
Capone was examined by a psychiatrist who
declared that the mobster "had the mentality
of a 12-year-old child".
Oh, and, when the bartender pours Lucifer
a drink, we get another little shout-out to
actress Rachel Harris's usual role in the
show and how Lucifer normally addresses her
as "Doctor" when Luci says:
"Oh, lovely. Just what the doctor ordered."
In episode 2, just before Chloe reveals to
Michael that she knows who he really is, she
shows him the bullet necklace Lucifer gave
to her in Season 3.
"It's the bullet from when you shot me.
Remember in the warehouse, early in our partnership?"
Chloe showing the bullet to Michael just before
she shoots him in the leg, exactly like she
did to Lucifer in Season 1, is a delicious
detail that proves Michael can't fool her.
"Once I shot Lucifer to prove he was the Devil,
and now I'm shooting you to prove you're not."
Interestingly, Michael betrayed himself in
his reaction when Chloe showed him the necklace,
because if you re-watch the moment, there's
a slight flicker of hesitation when she mentions
it:
"See?
Still have it on.
I can see that."
And on top of that, because Michael doesn't
know what the bullet necklace is, he also
doesn't realise that Chloe is technically
lying when she says she still has it on,
because she actually took the necklace off
towards the end of Season 3 when she got together
with Pierce and didn't wear it at all in Season
4.
After Lucifer and Chloe sleep together for
the first time, he asks her whether she feels
cold, making a joke about how in the first
season Chloe was adamant she'd never have
sex with him.
"I will never, ever, ever sleep with you.
Never."
"Playing hard to get, I like it."
"When Hell freezes over, Lucifer."
And notice that when Chloe arrives at Luci's
place that night, she's dressed in red, a
colour of passion and love, of course, but
also a colour closely associated with the
devil!
In the show, Lucifer often wears a little
red pocket square and the soles of his shoes
are also coloured red.
In fact, we saw only last season how the show's
costume department played on that colour association
in Eve's clothes
which went from being heavenly white to various
shades of red after she reconnected with Lucifer.
The morning after when Chloe wakes up, she
asks Luci if she was "snoring like a truck
driver".
She doesn't let him reply, but the moment
is a nice call-back to Season 1 when she woke
up in Lucifer's bed after getting drunk the
night before.
That time, nothing actually happened between
them, but as she leaves Lucifer tells her:
"You snore, by the way.
Like an Albanian field wench!"
Another funny Season 5 moment comes when Maze
decides to style herself exactly like Ella
in an effort to try and be nicer and learn
how to become more emotionally available,
as Dr Linda suggested.
"Oh, my God, I have that exact same shirt!"
"Yes, you did!"
"Wait.
Did you steal my clothes?"
Maze doesn't just get Ella's look down to
a T, she also hilariously tries to imitate
Ella's mannerisms.
And that moment reminds me of other such humorous
times on the show, including Season 2 when
Lucifer decided to "learn how to douche" and
dressed up and tried to be like Dan.
"Where to now, Twinsy?
Hmm?"
And then there was the time in Season 4 that
Eve dressed up as Chloe and also copied her
body language to try and get Lucifer's attention.
In Season 5, Ella almost seems to find her
geeky soulmate in Pete when he turns up with
tickets for a Star Trek convention and they
both start having a conversation in Klingon,
a funny little call-back to when Ella tried
to talk to Chloe in the fictional language
in Season 2:
"Ta' vonlu!"
"Ta' von what?"
"It's Klingon for 'the king is trapped.'
In Star Trek they play three-dimensional chess."
And there's an even geekier detail in the
clothes Ella wears to the convention.
Her uniform is blue, which is the colour worn
by science and medical personnel in Star Trek,
and that fits our Ella perfectly as she's
a forensic scientist.
There must be some big Stanley Kubrick fans
among the Lucifer crew as Season 5 has visual
shout-outs to not one but two of the iconic
filmmaker's movies.
In episode 2, Chloe's investigation into murderous
goings-on in a tech billionaire's space simulation
provides the perfect opportunity for a tribute
to 2001: A Space Odyssey.
The story kicks off with a call-back to the
film's spaceship and its sleek monochrome
design and the image of an astronaut making
their way up an octagonal walkway.
The next Kubrick reference pops up in episode
7 when Chloe and Lucifer head to the home
of a man they believe to be a serial killer.
Some Shining-esque music plays in the background
as a little boy pedals down a corridor on
a tricycle.
"Well, that bodes well."
Just as Danny Torrance rode around the corridors
of the Overlook Hotel in The Shining.
And the wallpaper in the apartment block corridor
also has vibes of The Shining hotel's carpet
about it, with its geometric pattern and orange
and brown colouring.
When Michael strides into the middle of a
shoot-out between Chloe and a bunch of bad
guys, he whistles the theme to the show.
Which Chloe immediately recognises because
this isn't the first time that tune has featured
in an episode.
Yes, back during a case involving a murdered
musician in season 2, Lucifer wrote a song
for Chloe that perfectly sums up both his
role in their partnership and the show's premise:
♪ Crime-solving Devil ♪
♪ It makes sense ♪
♪ Don't over think it ♪
Intriguingly, the plot of that season 2 episode
also involved Lucifer returning to LA out
of the blue after having spent time in hell
to save Chloe,
a situation which nicely mirrors the circumstances
in season 5, though this time it's Michael,
pretending to be Lucifer, who returns.
When Lilith is explaining to Lucifer the history
of her ring, she talks about how the Aztecs
threw her into a volcano.
"I survive, and...
somebody writes it on a stone tablet.
You know how these things start."
"I do."
Her comment about stone tablets is a reference
to the Ten Commandments that God gave to Moses,
which were inscribed on two tablets of stone,
and which form the basis of many of the rules
in Judaism and Christianity.
In the finale, Michael delights in preying
on Amenadiel's fears for his son Charlie,
really tapping into his anxiety about his
baby's ill health, growing up, and even his
mortality.
As Michael badgers Amenadiel about all this
and Lucifer joins in arguing against Michael,
we see the twins position themselves on either
side of their brother,
creating an image of a literal devil and angel
on Amenadiel's shoulders.
"But they grow up so fast."
"Don't listen to him, brother.
Don't let him get inside your head."
The interesting thing here is that the devil,
Lucifer, is the one appealing to Amenadiel's
better nature, while the angel, Michael, is
the one trying to make him indulge his worst
instincts.
Often in this angel-and-devil-on-the-shoulder
trope, the devil appears on the protagonist's
left side, as that's associated with evil,
while the angel appears on their right side;
however, here, Lucifer the devil is on Amenadiel's
right, while Michael the angel is on Amenadiel's
left, reinforcing the fact that Lucifer and
Michael act contrary to their prescribed roles.
This scene also reminds me of a similar moment
in Season 4.
"Lucifer, stop."
"Lucifer, do it."
When the killer's revealed in episode 6 during
a DJ set at Lux, it turns out to be a jealous
ex-husband.
And as he explains why he did it, green lights
swirl around him and there's even a shot that
makes it look as if they're radiating from
his head.
Of all the colours they could have chosen
to light this scene and frame the killer's
head, green is the perfect one as it's long
been associated with jealousy and envy.
The crucial moment at the very end of the
penultimate episode sees Dan arrive with a
gun and proceed to shoot Lucifer right in
front of Chloe.
Those with a keen ear might have noticed something
familiar about the soundtrack playing in the
lead up to that moment.
Yes, if you're a fan of the critically acclaimed
Netflix series Dark you might have recognised
the song playing in the background as Inside,
which played in the third and final season
of Dark.
The lyrics of the song, which plays subtly
in the background, perfectly rack up the tension
and enhance the dramatic build-up to Dan pulling
the trigger on Lucifer.
As a show Lucifer has always enjoyed making
meta references
"Sounds like a a soon-to-be-canceled TV show."
but in Season 5 there are so many that I'll
list some of the best here.
After Ella discovers that Chloe and Lucifer
have finally had sex, she explains her reaction
in the same way that many of the fandom's
Deckerstar shippers may well have felt before
that moment.
"I was so ready to have my Deckerstar dreams
crushed again."
"Why?"
"'Cause it's been one bummer after another
with you two.
I didn't want to get my hopes up."
And the tagline of the ¡Diablo! TV show is
'Don't tell HIM the Devil made you do it!'
which is a reference back to Lucifer's complaints
earlier in the series about humans trying
to pin the blame for their sins on him all
the time:
"'Oh, the Devil made me do it.'
I have never made any one of them do anything."
Which is why it's particularly funny when
Ella quotes the tagline back at Lucifer:
"Don't tell him the Devil made you do it."
And there's the moment when Lucifer comments
about the actor who plays Diablo and the script
notes he made about his character.
"He had a fascinating insight into the character.
Some wild theories about self-loathing, but
we can't get it all right."
This is, of course, a joke about Lucifer and
how his own self-hatred and sense of guilt
came to a head in Season 4, causing him to
transform into his full devil form.
Although Luci eventually recognised his self-hatred
back then.
"Why do I hate myself so much?"
Now that reference seems to have flown completely
over his head.
In the noir episode, down the alleyway outside
the Garden Club, there's a sign for the "Alibi
Room", a little in-joke for fans of procedural
shows like Lucifer.
A few other meta details are that KarnalGirl506,
one of Jed's jilted lovers, appears in Episode
506 of the series.
And in Episode 507, the fake Whisper Killer
lives in Unit 507.
Also Linda's daughter, Adriana Nassar, is
named after a Netflix Originals manager.
As you can see, Season 5 of Lucifer is really
packing in the call-backs to previous seasons,
so it's well worth making time for an epic
binge rewatch.
But as much as we love our streaming services,
it can be really frustrating to find the TV
show you want to watch, or the latest seasons
of it, aren't available in your country.
However, thanks to the sponsor of this video,
NordVPN, you can make these kinds of geo-restrictions
a thing of the past.
A virtual private network, or VPN, helps you
bypass geo-restrictions or censorship on content
not available to view in your country.
NordVPN can help you connect to many streaming
services.
Just pick a server in another location and
browse the internet as if you were there.
One thing we like about Nord is the super-fast
download speeds on its 5,000+ servers through
the use of new-generation VPN technologies
like Wireguard.
And unlike many free and slower VPNs, Nord
has a no-log policy meaning it doesn't record
or retain details of your online activity
when you're connected to its service.
Plus you can connect up to six devices at
the same time, including your laptop, tablet,
desktop, phone and home router so you can
cover all of your connected devices.
For a limited time, NordVPN are offering all
our viewers 68% off the two-year plan and
a bonus month absolutely free.
It works out at just $3.71 a month to secure
your online privacy with an additional month
for free.
Just visit NordVPN.com/Flicks or tap the link
in the video description to access the offer.
So what was your favourite moment in Season
5?
And did you spot any other easter eggs or
cool details?
Leave your thoughts in the comments below.
Tap left to watch my full Lucifer playlist
including part 1 ending explained and part
2 and season 6 theories.
Or tap right for another video you're sure
to like.
And if you enjoyed this, a thumbs-up and a
share are hugely appreciated.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!